so this is an example of one of the
places I visited in order to get to this
personal Journey that I was just talking
about in the middle of the field the
bulldozer pauses and out pops its driver
for a cigarette break it's a perfect
September Day in Northern Kentucky crisp
blue free a neighboring Dozer carves
anill ruts through the construction site
he's helping build the Amazon air Hub a
$1.5 billion site expected to host some
100 cargo airplanes 300 trucks and a
robotic sort Center sprawling over a
million square ft slated to open in 2021
it's currently a mess of construction
equipment and
barricades As Americans moved more of
their shopping online at the onset of
the 2020 pandemic Amazon sales increased
some 40% the company's revenues grew by
a mindboggling $100 billion an
efficiently scheduled Fleet of aircraft
will cut hours and days off already fast
delivery times if the North America
circuit ulatory system conveys packages
and goods to its every extremity this
corner of Kentucky represents its anill
heart ups and DHL and Wayfair has
distribution centers here 65% of the
population of the United States lives
within 600 square miles a one-day drive
or 90-minute flight away it's close to
five other airports to Rail lines and
rivers and ports nearly 3 billion pounds
of cargo pass through the Cincinnati
Northern Kentucky International Airport
annually a number that continues to rise
Amazon expands its Fleet something as
seemingly local as a main lobster might
be diverted West through Kentucky only
to be sent East again to an upscale
restaurant in New York the circulatory
system its trucks and airplanes and
conveyor belts and plastic bubble wrap
is kept in motion by a set of equations
and code this code tells each box where
to go and when in the most efficient way
undergoing all this is a set of
mathematical models that's explored each
possibility assigned probabilities and
planned contingencies and beneath this
set of models the hidden choreographer
is a way of looking at the
world so
that's that's what this book is
about